just when you think the entire Arizona
gubernatorial Fiasco involving Kerry
Lake can't get any more embarrassing
Kerry Lake yesterday was begging for
money desperate desperate claiming that
she's going to fight on despite the fact
that a judge has dismissed her final
challenge in her election loss for
Arizona governor back in November Now
understand that it has now been seven
months almost since she lost and when I
say she lost It's always important to
clarify what I mean is her opponent
Katie Hobbs received more votes judge
this this is a PBS report
from the Associated Press judge
dismisses Kerry Lake's last challenge in
election loss for Arizona governor a
judge on Monday dismissed the only
remaining legal claim in Republican
Kerry Lake's challenge of her loss last
year to Katie Hopps Maricopa County
superior judge Peter Thompson said Lake
failed to prove her claim that Maricopa
County did not verify signatures on mail
ballots as required by law this was the
final challenge so what does Carrie Lake
do yesterday she holds another one of
these delusional press conferences where
she comes up with reams of paper and
there's people standing behind her we
never know who the hell these people are
or what role they have in any of this
and then she begs for money she begs for
money
here's one here's one dear Kerry my
humble 20 donation for your continued
fights against the evils at the Arizona
and DC cartels wow
this is a 20 check this came from Sun
City West wow I mean I guys I could go
through this whole thing this these
letters
move me to tears yeah
the real reason she's crying is no Lee
no no judges are buying her BFS into
tears what's going on in our elections
and the people
are the ones who are helping us they
want they want our case to go forward
they want to keep sending money just to
fight this because they know if we don't
fight this now we're losing our country
it's not fun I I have been offered
bribes to get out of politics there's
that story where which was never
verified and no details were ever
provided
we have such a huge movement they're
afraid of this movement being back on
the ballot
it's true Bram they're afraid of this
movement being back on the ballot I've
actually had someone show up at my door
pretty powerful person offer me money to
not run sure office again they don't
want my name on the ballot they're that
scared of her
offered me whatever I wanted to put our
movement on ice for two years
foreign
funding for this effort we are going to
continue to take donations if people can
it seems as though you have quite
literally no more legal recourse are you
still going to collect donations
absolutely I I'm not here begging for
donations guys that's actually exactly
that's quite literally what she's doing
it's difficult putting food on the table
right now in Joe Biden's economy it's
very difficult so let me put aside as
she says this she puts aside she
realizes I should stop begging for
donations by taking envelopes out of
this bag of donut box of donations I
have so she puts it to the side as she
says I'm not here begging for donations
well I guess not in the next 10 seconds
asking for donations I want you to all
know that I am asking for people to get
involved Marissa is going to help we're
going to get people motivated excuse me
excuse me just admit it the people who
do make donations is going toward paying
for a legal fund oh so yeah you'll take
them and you have a use for them that's
great the how would I want to meet the
person donating to Carrie lake at this
point in time what on Earth could be
going through your mind if anything
for you to at this point say hey you
know what I think I'm gonna send Carrie
Lake money I'm gonna send her money at
this point in time I'm not here begging
for donations I'm merely talking about
how great the people sending money are
and reminding people we will continue
accepting donations but I'm not begging
for them now I guess in order to provide
some cover
plot even ostensibly for accepting
donations Kerry Lake now says she wants
to take this to the Supreme Court where
even this delusional right-wing Supreme
Court I don't think is going to hear
this case Newsweek reports former
Arizona gubernatorial candidate Kerry
Lake on Tuesday announced her intention
to keep pushing her election case
towards the Supreme Court after
suffering a major loss in court she made
the announcement after a judge ruled
that her legal team did not have
sufficient evidence to prove ballot
workers didn't conduct the signature
matching
um her challenges were consistently
dismissed in court including Mondays but
she pledged to continue fighting she
will try to prove her argument before
The Supreme Court she also all she often
makes this vague claim we proved our
elections are a mess we proved signature
verification is a joke she said she
wasn't surprised by the judge's decision
Lake also announced a new ballot chasing
initiative which he says was the largest
in Eros Zona this involves reaching out
to registered voters and assuring they
submit the ballots on time all this sort
of stuff so listen bottom line this is
going nowhere this is a complete and
total human accumulation but at the end
of the day the only reason that these
things last as long as they do the only
reason Kerry lake is still doing this
stuff after seven months is because
someone is donating money to her let me
give you a counter imagine a different
scenario imagine that on November 15th
or whenever it was that Kerry Lake first
announced that this was going to
continue for so long imagine no one
donated money to her
she wouldn't continue doing this for
seven months the reason that this
continues is that people continue to
donate money some people clearly people
who don't understand anything and uh my
guess is that many of the people sending
her money can't actually afford to do so
which is probably the saddest part of
this entire thing so is it finally over
yes and also now she's pushing for the
Supreme Court let's hope that doesn't
happen